así es juan costa de márfil con una
plantilla muy poderosa sobre todo de
mitad de cancha hacia adelante con
varios jugadores del fútbol europeo y
con la gran figura que sebastián a leer
en la delantera el goleador de la
vigente de champions switch se estará
debutando frente a guinea ecuatorial' la
única selección africana de origen
hispano y que justamente a raíz de este
origen tiene a 16 jugadores
naturalizados nacidos en españa pero que
son descendientes de ecuatoguineanos y
que terminan formando la base de esta
selección dirigida por juanmi ya que va
a disputar su tercera copa africana de
naciones pero por primera vez es se
clasificó por mérito propio las dos
anteriores habían sido a través de haber
sido el anfitrión del torneo claramente
son los favoritos lo que decíamos costa
de marfil pero van a tener una baja
importante la de su arquero silván
gueboguo que fue sancionado por la fifa
después de haber dado positivo en un
control antidopaje
y hablando de un tema más general de esa
copa africana de naciones llevamos nueve
partidos y apenas hemos visto nueve en
goles que es lo que está pasando
hay diferentes factores que confluyen
por un lado está históricamente es
habitual que al inicio de los torneos y
también con la paridad que existe en el
fútbol africano se produzcan pocos goles
equipos que por ahí
sobresalen por su físico logran
equilibrar a veces las diferencias con
otros más técnicos después hay una
preparación que estuvo muy afectada por
el joven 19 en casi todos los equipos y
también para aquellos que tienen muchos
jugadores situados en europa la
liberación de estos jugadores fue muy
poco tiempo antes del torneo es el caso
por ejemplo de argelia que tuvo y con
muchos inconvenientes ayer frente a la
sierra leona son jugadores que vienen
del invierno se tienen que adaptar
también a un clima mucho más cálido y ni
hablar en una ciudad como ésta como
aduana donde hay mucho más calor mucha
más humedad que en el resto de las sedes
y también ayer influyó el mal estado del
campo de juego es posible que el nivel
futbolístico y que los goles comiencen a
llegar con el correr del torneo
fue muchísimas gracias entonces por esa
información acerca de esta copa africana
de naciones